- On this episode, I talk
about piss poor things,
double consumption, and my
last five breaths in my life.
You ask questions, and I answer them.
This the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody, this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and welcome to episode 40
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Voiceover] Oto asks,
"I like how you talk
"about 'execution' in business.
"How do you prioritize which
project to execute first?"
- Oto, great question.
By the way, real quick,
thank you everybody
for getting me to 40. Also,
all the people watching,
I need you to get into the podcast.
Podcast people, watch.
I want people listening
and watching every episode.
Is that too much to ask?
I think it's double consumption.
It's #DoubleConsumption that's a hashtag,
want to see if any of
you use it on Twitter.
Oto, the way I prioritize is to equally
with my intuition, so
it's a judgment call,
equally take care of the
things that are most on fire,
the biggest problems, balanced
with going on the offense
on the biggest upside things
and the biggest things,
the culture, a new client.
So take care of these three
employees that are fighting,
and they're not getting along,
really, you know, on fire, or
a client that's really upset,
and then over here, strike the vision.
What are we doing with
the video department?
Where are we going?
Like, what am I doing?
Like, where's this all going?
How do I buy the jets?
And nothing in the middle.
Oto, VaynerNation, the
middle is dangerous.
- [Voiceover] Yoli asks,
"Before you had an assistant,
"how did you structure your day?"
- Yoli, first of all, I
just wanted to tell you
I appreciate all the interaction.
Thanks for being a supporter
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
By the way, back to the last question.
The middle is dangerous.
Pre-assistant.
I mean, it was a disa--
I was such a bad person, you know,
I had this power position at Wine Library,
where I was one of the biggest
wine buyers in the world,
or definitely in the U.S., in the world.
And nothing got to my
head, but I was like look,
somebody can wait 15 minutes or 20 minutes
if I'm like, you know,
finishing up this meeting.
They're here to sell me.
So I kind of took the, you
know, the buyer's approach
mentality to that.
But what was bad was I
would triple book people,
like literally, I used to
be like on floor at 11:30
in the morning helping
somebody with, you know,
a big selection for a
party, and I'd see like
somebody walk in, and be
like oh yeah, that's right,
I have a meeting with Craig.
And I'd be like yeah, you
should try this Pinot Noir,
and then I'd be like oh crap,
why did Frank just come in?
That's right, I have a meeting with Frank,
and I think it's at the same time.
That's bad, let me figure
out what I'm gonna do.
And by the way, you need a
little cheese for your party.
Why did Sally just walk in?
Holy crap, I'm triple booked,
and this would happen a lot.
And it was complete chaos,
it was disorganized.
It wasn't efficient, and it was piss poor.
- [Voiceover] Z asks, "If you were to jump
"in a time machine, travel back to speak
"to your 21 year old self,
and only have one minute,
"what do you say?"
- Z, I would tell that person
to hook up with more chicks,
and not work as many hours.
And I know that can be crass,
and obviously, you know,
what that crass statement
is really saying is have
a little more fun, right?
You're gonna accomplish your things.
You're gonna pull it off, you know.
I appreciate that you do
have business patience,
but you need to spend
a little bit more time
with your friends. You can
go on one more vacation.
You can go do a keg stand,
need to live a little bit
because you're gonna have a family,
which is gonna be amazing.
You're gonna be busy as crap,
and you're gonna run out of this time,
you're only 21 once.
- [Voiceover] Tiger
asks, "If your dad Sasha
"would of ended up in construction,
"how do you think it would
have affected your life
"without Wine Library?"
- Tiger, great question, and by the way,
this is a big shout out episode 40
for everybody who's asking for
a little bit more condensed,
we're keeping it tight on the four oh.
I wish I said to the 21 year
old self to drink more 40s.
That would have tied in the.
Anyway, Tiger, you know what?
I think about this a lot.
And I'm gonna, I promised myself,
and you guys have heard
me talk about this,
to be honest on this show,
and this is tough for me to say.
There is a big part of me that
thinks I'd be more successful
if I didn't go into the family business.
I wouldn't have had the head start
that many people can say
I had, and I respect that,
but my intuition tells
me that I would have
been even a little more hustler, right?
Maybe, maybe to a bad degree.
But I could see myself, my intuition,
and I've thought about
this a lot by the way,
is that I would have head out west
during the internet boom, I probably would
have had a company worth $800 million
going public in 1999,
that would have went to $1
in stock value, but I
would have learned things
in that that might've
made me bet even harder
on Facebook and Twitter
and Uber than I did,
and so, you know, my intuition,
maybe cause I have ego,
maybe because I have bravado,
is if my dad didn't have
an amazing set up for me
to go in to, if I didn't
fall in love with the
family business and
want to be a part of it,
and don't forget, I was
making a lot of money
selling baseball cards.
I could've went down that route.
There's just, I feel
like I would've really
found my way, and I feel that my dad
taught me honor and a
lot of conservativeness
that has helped me not
veer off or have losses,
but I think sucked out
a little bit of my speed
and aggressiveness, and that
may sound weird to you guys,
but I do believe that, and I do wonder if
man, I might have been
more financially along.
However, and let me put
this stake in the ground,
it's the best thing that
ever happened to me,
because forget about the monies,
those 10 years specifically
when I was full time
of spending that many hours with my dad,
when I'm on my last breath,
when I'm laying there
and I'm dying, there's
no question in my mind
that those will be one of
the two or three things,
obviously all the things I've
about to have with my kids,
probably a selfish thing about how many
Superbowls I won, but like, you know,
those, that, those 10 years with my dad
will definitely 100% be one
of the final five thoughts
as I die, and to me that is an incredible
accomplishment and
something I'm grateful for,
and very thankful for.
My friends, thank you for
watching episode four oh.
Question of the day.
This is a big one.
This is a, this, if you're
listening, if you're watching,
you need to pass this on
to the other VaynerNation,
I'm making this an iconic question.
This is a 10 year question.
Let me explain why.
In Big Answers on YouTube,
I want you to predict
the amount of shows
that The #AskGaryVee Show
will have all time?
Final, curtain, it will happen I'm sorry.
How many episodes of The #AskGaryVee Show
will I produce?
And a year or two after it's over,
I will go back and look at the comments,
team, and we will pick
everyone who guessed correctly
and invite them to dinner with me.
You keep asking me questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Oh crap, wait, subscribe!
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in socials.
So, subscribe!